[Music]
so it's great to be here and to see
everyone here and to have some time to
just really interact around issues that
I know are important to many of you in
the room that's how neighborhoods can be
built to best support kids and we've
been doing a little bit of work in this
area so what I wanted to do is just
share a couple of insights from our
group and then also get some feedback
from all of you in terms of the families
that you serve and the children that you
see in the communities that you serve
because that's incredibly helpful so
we've done a lot of work looking at
children in poverty and it's going to be
no surprise to you that the outcomes for
kids who grow up in low-income families
and low-income neighborhoods are worse
and recently we've started to pay a lot
more attention to issues of income
inequality right so what that distance
is between low-income children and their
neighbors and their peers and how that
might affect kids who are growing up in
these communities and so the good news
is that we found identified a number of
community strengths and family strengths
that can help to protect and buffer the
effects of poverty I'm going to talk
about a few of those and they're
probably gonna be no surprise to many of
you who've seen this in action and then
I'm going to turn to an issue that I
think and just conversations so far
today and talking about Regent's Park
and talking about other developing
communities this issue of where we go
from here on a policy level and the
building of mixed income communities in
schools and how we can build those in
ways that actually make sure those
resources in those communities in those
schools translate into good to good
outcomes for kids and in that work we
asked how the economic distance between
low-income children and their peers how
that influences their behavior and other
outcomes so you might have seen this
chart this is making the case of looking
at not just poverty but also income
inequality and so on the x-axis here
this is how unequal or equal resources
are distributed in various countries
right so these are among rich nations if
you're on this side income inequality is
low it means resources are distributed
quite equally within society according
to this Gini coefficient and here
we have high levels of inequality here
Mario and I are in the United States
Canada it's right here in the middle and
income inequality and what you have
plotted here is an index of child
well-being so these are 40 different
indicators of child well-being in health
and this linear relationship tells you
that if children growing up in in
countries where resources are
distributed quite equally across across
citizens that their outcomes their
children look much better and a whole
range of outcomes right even among rich
countries and if you go down here and
really high inequality places their
children do much worse and when you go
down to the state level within countries
we also have evidence that this is the
case so inequality might matter above
and beyond the income level of that
community or that that region so as we
watch income inequality grow and this
divide between the rich and the rest
this is something just to keep our eye
on in terms of how kids are seeing that
and how that might be influencing kids
so the study I'm going to talk to you a
little bit today is called the
environmental risk study and this is a
study of 2,000 kids growing up in
Britain so they're first assess at birth
and they've been assessed every few
years they're now in their 20s the last
time we saw them was age 18 when we saw
96% of these kids and so we go into
their homes and we we collect
information on everything from their
genetics to they're testing for how
they're doing in school in terms of
reading in terms of intelligence we do
tests on their parents and assessments
on their parents mental health and then
rob stamps and I had done some work
overlaying he's a neighborhood
researcher who's made really important
contribution to this area them done some
work mapping these children's
communities so how cohesive these
communities are how what poverty levels
are in the in these communities just to
look at how those factors relate to
children's mental health over time and
this year some results of that today
so this was called the community
strength study so we had this ongoing
longitudinal study we wanted to layer on
and understand you know what are the
communities of these kids what do they
look like Rob did this really wonderful
work in Chicago it was a systematic
social observation where people actually
went out onto the street
drove vans down the road videotaped
along the streets and encoded those
observations to get measures of kind of
what that community look like we started
in 2009 instead of buying vans we just
went in Google Street View and tried to
do the same thing there Rob did it
turned out at work for a lot of the
outcomes in terms of capturing some of
this some of this stuff so that was a an
interesting an interesting effort but so
here's some of the good news so we
tweaked we surveyed the residents so we
surveyed people that were living on the
same street and oftentimes the same
apartment block as the children in our
study and we asked them a bunch of
questions about how safe they felt to
the neighborhood how well they knew
their neighbors how well people looked
at out for children in the neighborhoods
we summarized in this measure of
collective efficacy that many of you
have probably heard about and Muriel
could probably talk a lot more about but
this is this level of social cohesion
right so how close people in the
neighborhood felt they were to each
other and how willing they seemed to be
to intervene in the common good right so
how likely would you be to stop a kid
who was about to get in trouble right
and so we were able to summarize all of
the neighborhoods in our study on this
dimension and one of the things that I
like to point out is here's you know in
our deprived neighborhoods in in Britain
here's a distribution of collective
efficacy right here so the mean is lower
in our most affluent neighborhoods but
you see some of our most cohesive and
supported neighborhoods are some of our
lowest poverty neighborhoods right I'm
sure you guys I see a lot of nodding
right so there's a lot of strengths we
get a lot of stereotypes of what what a
poor neighborhood might look like but
there's a lot of strengths within these
communities and we were interested in
seeing how those strengths whether they
protected kids that lived in them or
whether they conferred some benefits to
the families that were there in some of
our early work we did find exactly
exactly that so children from low-income
families if they were growing up in a
neighborhood that had high levels of
collective efficacy they actually looked
a lot better in terms of their behavior
problems at school entry right so there
was this added effect of and above the
family for this community level support
we also have done some work so these are
just two lines showing children's
trajectories of mental health across
time and this is antisocial behavior so
we expect at age 5 you've seen them the
kindergartens they come in there
if they fight and they our job is to
kind of socialize that out of them and
childhood and that's what happens
normally for kids here that gets in the
deprived neighborhoods and the kids from
the affluent neighborhoods but what
closes this gap is supportive parenting
right so strengths within we can make
this difference go away statistically by
accounting for whether or not that kid
has a supportive parent in the home
right so there are strengths at the
family level at the community level that
help to reduce these disparities and
many of you many of you know that
so the question we've had recently is
what does it mean for a low-income kid
to grow up in a mixed income community
right so we see child poverty rates we
see the number of children living in
poverty in the US the latest statistics
were just released and close to 50% of
US children live dangerously close to
the poverty line that's under that 200%
of the poverty line you know 15 million
live in families below the poverty line
so that's a lot of children living in
these conditions there are a lot of
targets to move families and move
children out of poverty but the number
of children living in poverty has
actually increased over the last 10
years the United States so one of the
solutions that's often put forward is to
create economically mix schools and
economically mix communities right and
to allow these children to have those
kinds of experiences and close this
opportunity gap so Robert Putman is a
great new book out the talks about the
differential investment that low versus
higher income children receive and so
ways to close that and kind of
equalizing the playing field right and
these policies we we like them I like
them but we wanted to test whether or
not children living in these kind of
communities whether they were in fact
doing better and so we went in and the
question was how do low-income children
fare when they grow up in the shadow of
wealth and increasingly in the shadow of
increasing wealth so here's an example
from the two neighborhood this
represents where the child in our study
lives and these are small very small
areas this is a point five mile radius
so when we track kids and figure out how
much they move during a day this is as
at age 12 about the average amount that
kids in this age travel by foot these
are very small levels of resolution in
the in the UK we can get output areas
which characterize very fine-grained so
smaller than
census block groups and the dark blue is
high poverty and the light white is the
most affluent neighborhood so you can
see that these are two low-income
children one that's living in
concentrated disadvantage and one that's
living in a more affluent neighborhood
attending a more affluent school right
so the question was which child would be
better so some of you know the answer if
you read the work so you know we think
that this child should benefit from
going from a better school having lower
rates of crime levels poverty around him
in fact what we found when we looked at
this across a number of measures and
over time was the was the opposite okay
and I want to take you through that
finding just so we can start to think a
little bit more about what the cause of
it might be and what some of the
solutions could be in terms of
understanding this this is antisocial
behavior one of our measures so these
are kids these are low-income kids
growing up in the concentrated poverty
and these are their scores on an
anti-social behavior score scores as
rated by parents and teachers so these
kids have lower levels of antisocial
behavior as rated by parents and
teachers than their peers so you might
say okay well that's just how parents
and teachers see kids right and that's
what I thought initially but when we go
in and we actually do in-home testing we
find a similar pattern of results right
so when we're testing them on what
they've learned in school when we're
getting self-report to them how much
they're drinking later on what kind of
behaviors are engaging in so the low
income kids in our in our study they
grew up what we called in the shadow of
wealth they tended to be doing a little
bit worse so we found this again across
this is educational success this is we
had teacher ratings we had educational
actual testing in the homes and found
this similar pattern right so these kids
low-income kids in concentrated poverty
we're actually scoring higher than their
peers living in higher income areas we
tried to control for the factors that
might account for why families moving to
area these kind of areas and the effect
remained so the findings were for boys
only and this is interesting reason
they'll talked about in a sec second
they were similar across this age in 12
weeks
four family neighborhood factors and
that age 18 we found a similar a similar
pattern so this is just an example of at
age 18 for substance use what we find so
do our findings generalize this is a
British studies we wanted to know is
this something unique about the British
experience we know from the moving to
opportunity study some of you may know
that this was a study where they offered
housing vouchers to families our mothers
who were living in low-income areas 15
there's been positive and negative
findings from the study it's a bit
controversial but 15 years on the boys
were still doing poorly on measures of
mental health they did find they have
found some positive effects on things
like well-being and BMI for example but
they find higher conduct disorder PTSD a
mental health problems for the boys they
do find some improvements for girls and
when they go in and do the qualitative
work on this what they find for girls is
reduction in fear of violence when they
move into the new neighbourhoods what
they find for boys is a story that goes
along the lines and not being fully
accepted in these new neighborhoods
being potent seen potentially as a
threat and then girls spending a little
bit more time inside versus outside of
the home there's a add health study in
the United States and this is about
17,000 kids across the US and Rob krosno
who's a sociology has looked at this
also and found that low-income kids who
go to school with a greater percentage
of middle and upper income kids they
tend to do worse on social emotional
outcomes and they tend to do worse on
test scores and this finding is largest
for the for minority children right so
again not a not a good story to tell but
I think an important one to hear to
think about how we could could make
these settings a little more welcoming
to to low income children so one of the
things that we thought about in looking
at this is whether these kinds of
settings it may evoke something that
similar to stereotype threat and kids so
making the low SES a very highly salient
thing for children and whether or not
how children see themselves on a ladder
like relative to others whether that
might be explaining some of these
effects and so we've looked at we've
looked at this in the
IRA's sample as well and so we asked
kids to basically think of where they
are in relation to other people in
theirs in the country and they put
themselves on a ladder from poor to to
very rich and what what we find time and
time again and other people so people
have found this also that it's not just
how much money or income your family has
it's in addition to that where you think
you fall on this ladder that matters so
where you perceive yourself to be in
this in this ranking and it pricks all
kinds of health outcomes so here are
just some examples of what we we looked
at this was conduct disorder kind of
substance use depression anxiety and so
these results hold so where you put
yourself on the ladder and how you're
doing they hold regardless of whether
the kid tells us about how they're doing
the parent and other informant and
official test score they control after
we can control for something called
neuroticism which is basically how
pessimistic the kid is about things in
general and then in this study if you
remember they're twins they hold four
kids in the same family and so this is
important because people have said well
you know it's where someone views or
puts themselves on a social ladder
that's just kind of capturing how much
money they actually have and you don't
have a good measure of how much you have
but here we have two kids that are
growing up in the same family and if
they differ in terms of their
perceptions of where they are relative
to others that's predictive as well so
there's some sort of signal that might
be happening here in terms of how kids
perceive their social status relative
others that might be important in
helping to understand why why the kids
in our sample are doing a little bit
poorly in the low-income so I think some
of the implications we've looked at this
and said that the economic distance
so between low-income children and their
higher income peers and poverty might
create a double disadvantage a form a
double disadvantage for low-income kids
you know I think like many of you I hold
a lot of hopeful assumptions for mixed
income communities and I wouldn't want
anyone to walk away from this talk with
the idea that I'm saying economically
mixed communities or schools don't work
a lot of them do work there's evidence
that many attempts to do this are
successful but I think it's important
that we continually check our hopeful
assumptions about them being the
solution against data on how kids are
doing right and so this is
mean that poor and more affluent
children should live apart should attend
different schools you know that would
certainly be the wrong answer but you
know we need to stop and actually
collect the information on how
low-income children are doing in those
settings how they're feeling in those
settings and whether they can access
these types of resources and I have to
put up this example because it's so
outrageous but it illustrates this point
and it's very recent it's 2015 and this
is an article from The New York Times
and it's about a poor door and this is a
very high-rise luxury apartment in
Central Park and the idea was that a
certain percentage of the units in this
new luxury apartment would have lower
income housing embedded so those could
kids could attend good schools grow up
in a better neighborhood the application
process it was a lottery and it was just
an overwhelming response but what the
builders did is they put in a poor door
so if you qualified for the subsidized
rental you entered in a different door
then the regular paying residents and
this isn't actually uncommon this is the
way that in England and we live there as
well that the mixed income communities
were structured so this is a very kind
of blatant example how communities can
be built in ways that are isolating and
reinforced the economic distance and
this is a pretty simple fix right and
many of you are probably doing much more
complicated sensitive things to reduce
that distance but just in terms of
building the physical environment in
this way you know kind of violates
almost everything we know about building
a sense of belonging and inclusivity and
and feeling like people can own the
space that they're in so with that I
just want to stop and kind of thank the
wonderful people that have have worked
on this project and went through that
fairly quickly but I want to make sure
that there was time and then if people
want all the papers are on our website
and adapt lab org so I welcome you to go
check that out
you